le stade iii de l'épidémie sera atteint
d'ici une à deux semaines c'est ce qu'a
déclaré le professeur jean françois
delfraissy
à l'issue d'une réunion à l'elysée entre
les acteurs de la recherche publique et
privée et le chef d'état on ne touche
personnelle quand on va arriver au stade
3 en france qu'on essaie de gagner parce
que du temps parce que ça permet à la
fois de circonscrire le ballet les zones
déjà les plus touchés d'une part et
deuxièmement ça permet aussi peut-être
de se mieux se préparer pour ce phase
iii disons qu'on est dedans de l'ordre
de quelques jours ou d'une ou deux
semaines maximum
parmi les plus gros foyers en france le
haut rhin et notamment cette église
évangélique de mulhouse responsable de
dizaines de contamination dans tout le
pays du 17 au 24 février
près de deux mille fidèles ont participé
à une semaine de jeûne et de prières
alors les personnes qui ont fréquenté
donc notre église durant cette semaine
venez un peu de partout pour nous c'est
difficile de savoir exactement parce
qu'à pas d'inscription l'entrée est
libre mais disons que ça vient à peu
près de la france entière
il ya des personnes qui viennent aussi
des pays limitrophes notamment la
belgique l'allemagne la suisse donc le
monde francophone des personnes qui
viennent même de le guyane qui ont été
présents milieu de nous les antifas
voyez un peu partout parmi eux le
docteur jonathan peterschmitt confiné
chez lui il expliqué très prudent pour
ne pas être source d'autres
contaminations
non moi je ne suis pas du tout alarmés
tout simplement parce que je constate
effectivement que nous sommes
physiquement très bien il n'y a pas de
y'a pas de souci pour nous je suis par
contre très prudents tout bêtement parce
que ce que je ne voudrais pas c'est que
du fait de ma contamination jeu soit la
source d'autres contaminations
potentiellement plus embêtante mais je
ne suis pas du tout alarmés à paris les
reports d'événements se poursuivre
prévu le 5 avril le marathon se
déroulera finalement le 18 octobre
prochain
[Musique]